rachel what's going on how can we help
so my husband and i have been
married for three years um we have two
little kids
and he has some um some really bad
habits um for lack of a better word that
he
has always had since he was probably a
teenager and things like that that
um weren't weren't really a problem when
we were dating things like that but now
they're really starting to affect his
health and our family and it's been
bringing me
a lot of anxiety about what our future
is going to look like if they they
continue so what's going on what are
they
um so i guess the main one is he has
really severe asthma
um and he also smokes a lot um like a
pack a day kind of
sometimes less but around that and it's
actually he's been admitted to the
hospital twice in the last year for
breathing related issues yikes for like
three plus days each time
um and things like that it just seems to
be getting worse instead of better
other things related to that too but it
just makes me
uh worried you know with two little kids
he's only 32 and i'm 25 and i just feel
like
these are things you shouldn't be
dealing with for a long time sure these
kinds of health health issues
so um if i drill down here is it there's
something more than smoking
i mean it's it's all kinds of just
unhealthy not
taking care of himself really well
unhealthy eating unhealthy
lots of drinking not like in a
in a dangerous way or anything but just
just a lot of those types of habits
okay so when when
this is the uh the powerlessness part of
being
married to somebody who doesn't take
care of their body right
um you know that you can't make him eat
well
you know that you can't make him quit
smoking or stop drinking or stop
you know i don't know what i'm playing
video games so 2am whatever you
can only deal with you so when you see
these behaviors
what has your strategy been over the
last year or the last two years
how do you approach him with your
concerns
um i've probably tried everything
including the things that don't help at
all like
expressing to them how concerned it
makes me and how i don't like our
our kids learning from those behaviors
and watching him do these things and
a lot of probably guilt which i'm sure
is not the right approach but
um it's hard though right i mean i'm not
here i'm not gonna beat you up of course
man
those things are hard and it's important
for him to know how you feel on it
um when you sit him down and say hey
listen
i love you and at this current
trajectory you're not going to be with
us very long
and the time you are going to have with
us is going to be less than
because you don't feel good you don't um
you don't feel healthy or whole and when
you don't feel healthier whole you're
short with us you snap at us you end up
in the hospital
fill in the blank here what's his
response to you how does he how does he
how does he respond um he
always makes me feel really heard and
then nothing
changes he says i understand i can see
why you feel that way
you know kind of all those things but
but nothing
or i know i know i need to do something
different but okay
doesn't it doesn't change have you told
them that that you're scared
yes that you're scared you're gonna end
up a single mom
yes i i think he has
he has a lot of things from um before i
knew him like a lot of childhood things
that sure
i think um he probably doesn't really
want to deal with but i'm sure
contribute to some of these choices
of course i do of course so here's the
part you're going to have to
wrestle with you're probably already
there
i'll just ask you is it gotten to a
point where you
believe he's choosing these behaviors
that you know are going to kill him
that he's choosing this over you and
over your kids
um i i don't know if i want to say that
he does it intentionally
no not intentionally but really good
yeah not intentionally but
at the end of the day there's one road
to
being with you guys for a long time and
then there's one road to
a much shorter a much shorter less
healthier life
then yes i mean i think i think he knows
i don't know if he um
really applies it to his life like yes
this is going to shorten my life and
everything but i'm sure
he's heard that from his doctors and for
me and he knows that and
they just don't don't change and
i know i can't change him i know that's
what every good
counselor will say can i tell you rachel
i i
it's heartbreaking for me and i'm sorry
i got i wish there was a um like oh
you just need to and you can't
at the end of the day if you've sat down
and looked in the eye and said i'm
scared to death i'm gonna lose you and
i'm scared to death that our little
our little babies are gonna be without
you
and i'm asking you on behalf of us and
on behalf of yourself
somebody who i love i want you to love
yourself as much as i love you
and he says man i hear you baby and then
he goes outside and smokes he goes
outside and has a few more drinks
um i want you to know i get that's
heartbreaking
i hate that for you i hate that for
every spouse every partner in the
country
whose husband or wife girlfriend or
boyfriend don't love them as much as
they do
right they don't love themselves as much
as their partner does i hate that for
you
the best you can do in this situation is
number one
go see somebody yourself on how to
process this because this doesn't get
better it gets harder
okay there is some hope
that he begins to see you taking care of
yourself
and it's not an immediate turnaround but
it becomes
a long slow turn
right you start walking taller you start
doing the things that you can do
which are very limited to take care of
you and your and your kids
the second thing is is you can make some
declarations in your home you're not
going to be drunk in this house
you're not going to smoke inside this
house and subject the kids to this stuff
right um i'm assuming that he's
otherwise a great human being and he's a
good dad and a good husband right is
that fair
yeah and he respects any of the
boundaries he's set up like i've
told him i don't want the kids to see
him smoking and he always you know goes
outside and around the corner and
away from them and stuff like that so he
tries to respect those things
so he's man so can i tell you i've got a
an especially big heart for folks with
big hearts who are trapped
you know what i mean who are just
trapped i would love for you to tell him
to give me a shout i'd love to talk to
him
not in a mean or ugly way but just to
say man
i get it and i know and there's healing
if you want to make some major changes
in your life um
until then you're gonna have to decide
what your
breaking point is what your if then
point is
and i'll tell you that you know this but
i'll just repeat it
blaming criticizing um complaining those
things
never solve connection level issues
and we're in the middle of what i would
call it's a they're called diseases of
despair have you heard that term
yeah like we're experiencing that at
unfathomable levels particularly in men
who are just they're calling it
long-tail suicide right
they are just intentionally not taking
care of themselves over a long period of
time they know what they're doing is
slowly
slowly taking them out of the ball game
and they're just not making changes
because it's hard it is hard and i'm
asking every guy
if that's you listening to this go get
the help and care that you need
i want you to hear rachel's voice i want
you to hear a
a mom who loves her babies i want you to
hear a wife
who loves her husband and the husband's
a good guy
he just can't get over this idea that
the guy he sees in the mirror is worth
sleeping all night it's worth being able
to run around and play with his kids
without having to bend over and
catch his breath is worth being healthy
and living a long long healthy life
rachel i don't have a magic thing for
you then you got to take care of
yourself and you got to make sure you
and your kids are safe
taking care of yourself might be how do
i how long do i keep loving this guy
because i'm going to get i'm going to
get pulled underwater too i hope you'll
stay
connected to him and love him the best
that you know how
and i hope he will man
be inspired by you be inspired by that
connection and sometimes
somehow some way come to the realization
that he has value it may be man maybe
invite him to couples counseling maybe a
third neutral party will help
have him call my show but this one this
one doesn't always have a happy ending
it just doesn't and i hate that for you
oh man